er hat in unsere wohnung geld herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einem erneuten video von
diesem der grad an unterhosen denkt ich
frag mich echt mittlerweile gar nichts
mehr
wir spielen heute mal wieder dass sie
meine lieben freunde was ist eigentlich
mit dieser stütze hier
ich dachte ich könnte weg machen aber
das einzige was sich daran machen kann
es planschen geil luca ralph föhr möchte
vorbeikommen und abhängen ist nicht der
der er uns den hund gebracht hat ok also
keine ahnung was jetzt passieren wird
dieser ralf olbrich doch ja da ist der
reifen oftmals schön an genauso schön
luca ist natürlich wieder am pc alltag
in später luca ich will dich gar nicht
stressen aber das steht da ein kollege
vor der tür wo er kommt jetzt einfach
rein
luca ist immer noch am pc kannst bitte
deine sexy latschen ausziehen alter
stand gerade einer pfütze was hat er
eigentlich an alter so blaue schwulen
eine pinke rose in spanisch schwarze
jacke und dann hat er auch noch so rote
haare aber die beiden unterhalten sich
jetzt glaube ich erst mal ich war in
meiner früheren kindheit mal als tino
verkleidet dann kam die polizei weil sie
dachten ich wäre ein echter dino und
dann wollten sie mich in knast stecken
und das war echt mega krass weil da hab
ich dann über die physik und chemie
gelernt ich wäre am computer das ist
nämlich auch das ding meine lieben
freunde in der letzten folge habe ich
mir diesen kleinen kapelle gekauft ist
der nette und er träumt jetzt immer so
ein bisschen in meiner wohnung rum
das heißt mich fakt ist ehrlich gesagt
gerade leicht ab dass dieser ralf fällt
jetzt hier ist und wir uns nicht mit dem
hund beschäftigen können als unwahr ist
so mario kral fällt eigentlich bitten zu
gehen also ich glaube wir schmeißen den
ralf fällt hier jetzt gerade raus die
beiden verabschieden sich jetzt gerade
schon mal ein bisschen vorjahr hatte
noch ein bisschen bla bla bla bla also
er muss auf ihr ich muss los danke dass
du die zeit genommen hast ja kein
problem die drei minuten die du bei mir
war es waren echt die besten drei
minuten meines lebens nicht allerdings
beschäftigen wir uns jetzt mal wieder so
ein bisschen mit dem kleinen hunde
warum will er eine spülmaschine keine
ahnung was er da erkennt er mich dann ja
auch nicht drauf klicken ich kann mir
nur oh ich kann meine waschbecken
verbessern
also diese folgen mit lukas unechten
interessantesten und dann kann ich nicht
mehr verbessern weil ich das level noch
nicht erreicht hat cool
seit wann braucht man scheiß level um
seinen waschbecken besser zu machen
luca chillt nur am pc und der hund
schild daneben luca fühlt sich unwohl
das heißt wir klickt man auf die dusche
streichen wir dass mit dem pc immer die
zeit mit sind fordert der luca ist es
wieder nackt währenddessen schläft unser
kleiner hunde hier vorne
das ist ja immer noch ein welpe der ball
das heißt wir müssen aber wirklich
endlich mal mit diesem hund was machen
und dafür heute machen wir mal eine
komplette balu episode einmal als
nächstes machen wir hier mal streicheln
dass der lukas ja wahrscheinlich
darunter beugen genau schön abwarten bis
ich irgendwann selbst grund also der
hund zeigt auf jeden fall hier dass er
ein herz für uns empfindet also er mag
uns anscheinend als nächstes klicke ich
mal auf streicheln umarmen und hochheben
hatten wir schauen nicht mal loben da
sagt luca daumen hoch
ja das sehe ich genauso
dann klicken wir als nächstes mal aufs
instagram tier ich habe keine ahnung was
das
na gut dann nehme die kamera mal und
platzieren die hier
dann nehmen wir jetzt noch hier das hier
ein bisschen weiter weg
dann machen was hier sollte war da ja
geil zwischen den beiden durch so das
können wir hier fehlt klicken wir hier
unten mal auf noch blitz aktivieren
mit mama zack hier fotos übrig klar
daneben auch in anderen filter haben wir
noch den hier rein auch noch ein foto
machen da man mal wieder aufdrehen wir
mal ein bisschen von der seite machen
wir mal so hier noch ein filter zack
dann machen wir jetzt mal noch mal her
kann man immer noch sagt und jetzt weil
nur 13
also keine ahnung was das jetzt bedeutet
ehrlich gesagt oh mein gott ich kann ihn
auch auf den hund draufklicken ja jetzt
schilder da einfach mal schauen was wir
noch machen können wir können immer noch
ein großes leckerchen geben
das heißt es kostet 10 dollar glaube ich
zehn söhnen leon
das heißt er bekommt jetzt ein
leckerchen
ja und wir haben ja auch noch die option
was ist das schicke deinen hund rund um
das haus auf die suche machen wir das
jetzt mal das heißt dann könnt ihr mit
blumen bisschen ums haus herum laufen
und der erschnüffelt so ein bisschen die
umgebung luca wir sind noch immer in der
wohnung allerdings ist bei jetzt schon
auf dem weg hier alles ab zustände
füllen und geht wieder zum spieler david
zu putzen oder was ist kann doch nicht
so schwer sein dass selbst einfach raus
geht aus der haustür aus meinen dass so
was ist das denn löwenmäulchen pflanze
falls euch übrigens fragt warum es hier
die ganze zeit nur am pissen ist bei mir
in der sims welt
das liegt daran weil es gerade frühling
ist und ich habe dieses jahreszeiten
der nächsten episode sollte dann auf
jeden fall sommer sein das heißt jetzt
scheiße regen hier weg ist die sache ist
dass lukas sich mehr irgendwie für
diesen bereich interessiert also
fernseher und computer als für seinen
hund hier vorne allerdings wären wir das
ganze jetzt mal ändern das heißt nicht
immer wieder auf den hund drauf wir
haben diese ganzen sachen ja eigentlich
alles schon gemacht außer das geschäft
natürlich zu erledigen
ja sehr gut balloon ich habe keine
ahnung was er jetzt hier macht er jagd
auch noch dahin sehr gut balu jetzt
stell dir deine kaká ich denke mir auf
aufheben dann kann luka das schön
bekommen wo läuft der was jetzt denkt er
anregen
was sind das jetzt geht ja jetzt fängt
er wieder handcomputer hab ich richtig
wertvoll krise alter luca die komplette
episode heute sollte um den zweiten
gehen und er zählt nur hat seinen schein
elektronischen geräten
ich meine ich stehe eigentlich gerade
auch vom computer das stimmen also so
weit entfernt voneinander sind wir zwei
ist auch tatsächlich nicht so richtig
ich klicke allerdings trotzdem bei der
schweiz ag im weg ich leg trotz mal
wieder auf balou darauf die ganzen
sachen die hier stehen haben wir schon
gemacht das heißt ich denke jetzt auf
mehr auswahl und was macht luca ortega
ich richtig komplett krise mit dir jetzt
rennt er da oder war es die zeit läuft
jetzt gerade mega schnell luca band
gerade ich bald tut mir so leid alt hat
schild einfach vom bett und wartet
darauf dass wegen wie was machen 2000
jahre später aufgestanden
gehen musste
luca celik ich glaube aber luca geht es
nicht gut der satz schon auf dem klo
gerade richtig schlecht aus also der
hatte jetzt nicht so ein lachen im
gesicht
jetzt ist ja auch mit das ist gerade
vier uhr am und hier steht auch er fühlt
sich immer noch unwohl also wir müssen
uns eine bedürfnisse anscheinend auf den
vordermann bringen
was war denn da er denkt an an die
toilette also keine ahnung was seine
mission gerade ist er wird jetzt
natürlich denkt er auch wieder an den
geschirrspüler aber luca geht's auf
jeden fall erstmal wieder ein bisschen
besser
er schaut fernsehen um 4 uhr 42 in der
nacht ich würde sagen wir sprechen immer
das essen weg
das fernseh gucken weg und du räumt
jetzt mal die schale hier auf dass wir
ein bisschen auf vordermann kommen ja
und jetzt hat luca gerade stundenlang
gepennt und jetzt wo ich wach bin
pentalog dieser haushalt ist der
bescheidenste auf dem ganzen scheiß bild
straßen planeten
also das ist gerade die situation in der
wir uns befinden es ist 25 in der nacht
beziehungsweise haben ganz frühen morgen
ein luca sitzt am pc schild irgendwo rum
bei luca luka durchsetzen
hat luca die ganze tier kekse gegessen
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend ich weiß überhaupt nicht mehr
was hier los ist
das mal auf hier genau ich bin mal
wieder ein bisschen vor so und jetzt
warten wir mal okay ballouz auch schon
wieder wach das heißt ein neuer tag ist
angebrochen tier ängste dass kein tier
ist vollkommen furchtlos ist bei juni
war es natürlich ist balu furchtlos
jedes jetzt einen eigenen ängste also
beobachtet ein haustier um
herauszufinden was ihnen angst macht
okay kann ich kann ich was das bedeutet
dieser knopf hier wir sollen balu
beobachten was er hat erst vor den süßen
bodens luca läuft natürlich direkt zu
dem hund hin und versucht mit dem mund
zu reden beziehungsweise sich freundlich
von ok ok der mag mich nicht locker
versucht es jetzt ein bisschen anders
der hund sieht ein bisschen traurig aus
tatsächlich sitzt jetzt hier ab home
also das hat auf jeden fall geklappt ich
kann ihn noch streicheln vielleicht
macht das thema spaß einem streich kein
hund mag es nicht gestreichelt zu werden
ja okay okay das mag ja auch der heiß
beckett und ist ein erwachsener streuner
also der hund gehört auch niemanden
das heißt wir versuchen jetzt einfach
mal eine dran zu packen und wir haben ja
mund wir haben zwei hunde jetzt in films
beginnt das heißt wir bringen den hund
jetzt einfach mal mit nach hause im wald
zeigt überhaupt keine regung speckels
also dieser schrott gab er hat in unsere
wohnung geklagt er gibt es dich an dein
herz was
ich habe keinen plan was jetzt irgendwie
abgeht
er hat auf jeden fall keinen bock auf
computer das heißt eigentlich ist es
nicht der richtige und liga-cup der
gerade er kann doch jetzt nicht
er hat angst ich glaube der hat angst
vor computern jetzt versuche dein
schwanz zu beißen also ich habe keine
ahnung was mit dem hund hier richtig
abgeht habe mich würd mal sagen wir
streicheln die noch ein bisschen dann
reden wir mit dem wir loben den wir
lernen noch ein bisschen kennt nicht nur
ein bisschen die zeit vor dass das ganze
ein bisschen schneller geht einem
einfach dass eine bessere bindung zu dem
hund aufbauen ihr seht schon der grüne
balken geht über leider überhaupt nicht
voran aber gut ich glaube der hund
markus auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen mehr
balu mag uns auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen mehr als der hund aber ich
würde sagen in der nächsten folge freuen
war dann mal die beiden hunde
miteinander an
das ist an der zeit bis heute videos als
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch dieser zinsvorteil drei
mittlerweile her schon gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video dann schreiben wir uns in die
kommentare
was ich in der nächsten folge mit diesen
beiden vollidioten anstellen soll
[Musik]